نريد طبيب التشخيص الخاص بك في
حالة تيد كروز الغريبة ،
دعنا نستمع إلى هذا
آه نعم عندما أتحدث إلى كاميرا التلفزيون ،
لن أرتدي قناعًا
وقد تم تحصيننا جميعًا ،
لذا فنحن نرحب بك في
الخطوة  بعيدًا إذا كنت تحب
الهدف الكامل من إرشادات القرص المضغوط للقاح ،
فإن ما نتبعه هو أن
سانجاي الحقيقي هو أنه يتبع إرشادات cc أنه
عندما تكون حول مجموعة من المراسلين
لا تحتاج إلى ارتداء قناع ساحر جدًا.
لا في الواقع ، إنه ليس
توجيه cdc ، لقد قمت بسحبه
مرة أخرى لأن التوجيه لا يتغير بشكل
واضح ولكنه يقول أنه حتى لو
تم تطعيمك بالكامل ، فأنت بحاجة إلى الاستمرار في
اتخاذ
الاحتياطات في الأماكن العامة مرتديًا
قناعًا على بعد ستة أقدام من
الزحام لتجنب الازدحام  لذا فإن الأمر
ليس كذلك ، أعني أنني أدرك أن هذا
يعكس محادثة يجريها
معظم المجتمع
الآن فيما يتعلق بما يمكنك فعله
إذا تم تطعيمك بالكامل ،
فالقلق هو أنه
بالنسبة له يتمتع بحماية جيدة
ميلادي  قصدًا ضد الإصابة بمرض شديد
يتطلب دخول المستشفى ، لا أعرف
اللقاح الذي حصل عليه ، لكنهم جميعًا
جيدون في الوقاية من
وجود مشكلتين أولاً وقبل كل شيء ،
فهم ليسوا مثاليين ، لذا لا يزال من
الممكن أن يمرض أيضًا.  البطاقة البرية هنا كما
تحدثنا عنها هي هذه المتغيرات
على الرغم من أنه يجب أن يكون
محميًا جيدًا ضد المرض الشديد
والاستشفاء من المتغيرات التي قد
لا يكون محميًا بشكل جيد ضد
المرض المعتدل والمرض الخفيف والقليل
واحتمال قدرته  لا يزال
ينقل الفيروس إلى شخص آخر ، لذلك
عندما لا يرتدي قناعًا
، فمن المحتمل أن يعرض الأشخاص الآخرين في
تلك الغرفة للخطر ،
الأمر بهذه البساطة أعني أننا
نتحدث عن هذا لأشهر حتى الآن
أن المعادلة لم تتغير بعد عندما
يكفي  لقد تم تطعيم الأشخاص
عندما خفضنا معدلات انتقال الفيروس
منخفضة ، وهذا هو الوقت الذي يمكننا فيه أن نبدأ على
الأرجح في التراجع عن هذا